صحيفه لوفيجارو نشرت مقالا يرى ان نتنياهو
يحاول فرض فكره الحرب الطويله من خلال
اسراره المتواصل على ما يسميه النصر
الكامل لكن المقال يتوقع استنادا الى
خبراء ان الخسائر الكبيره التي يتكبدها
الجيش خلال المعارك في غزه ستجبر الحكومه
في النهايه على مناقشه انهاء الحرب
بالاضافه الى تحديات القتال داخل وسط حضري
وتزايد الاعباء الصاديه بسبب
الحرب تناول مقال اخر في صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز الشكوك المتزايده كما يقول في قدره
اسرائيل على تفكيك حماس جاء في المقال ان
منتقدي الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه يعتبرون
هدف القضاء على حماس غير واقعي وقد يكون
محاله وحسب محللين اقصى ما يمكن ان تحققه
اسرائيل هو اضعاف القدرات العسكريه لحماس
بل ان ان تحقيق هذا الهدف المحدود سيحتاج
الى جهد
كبير ينطلق تقرير بصحيفه الجارديان من
حديث وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه عن رفض
نتنياهو طلبات من المساد والشباك ووزاره
الدفاع مناقشه خطه ما بعد الحرب في غزه ثم
يعلق بالقول ان نتنياهو ربما يرغب في
تاجيل مثل هذه المناقشات بهدف حمايه منصبه
ضمن حكومه وحده مرتبطه بالحرب تزول
بانتهائها وقد يفكر نتنياهو ايضا في ان اي
حل في غزه بعد الحرب يشمل جهات فلسطينيه
يهدد استقرار حكومته
الائتلافيه في صحيفه الاندبندنت نقرا عن
مرحله ثالثه من الحرب على غزه شنت خلالها
القوات الاسرائيليه هجمات على اكثر
المناطق اضاضا بالسكان تشير الصحيفه الى
تحذيرات وكالات الاغاثه التي تصف واقعا
صعبا لا يجد فيه النازحون مكانا امنا اما
بسبب القصف والمعارك او بسبب الاكتظاظ
الذي نتج عن نزوح نحو
55% من سكان القطاع نحو
الجنوب قلل مقال في صحيفتها ارتس من حظوظ
بايدن في ان يكون وسيطا فعالا للدفع نحو
حل سياسي لما بعد الحرب في غزه وبرر
المقال طرحه بالتذكير بان بايدن قدم دعما
استثنائيا لاسرائيل وجعل الولايات المتحده
مرتبطه اهداف الحرب الاسرائيليه ما افقده
المصداقيه بين الفلسطينيين وفي العالم
[موسيقى]
العربي